hey I'm Peter Rubin I'm Kelly Rubin this
is Crosby this is split screen because
we know there's always more than one
side to every story in every movie every
game every TV show TV shows like last
man on earth which has season one finale
this sunday night on Fox it's already
been renewed so we know we'll see it
next year it's also the product of the
creative partnership of phil lord chris
miller who made the jump street movies
and lego movies and Will Forte who we
love from SNL you guys just interviewed
anthem recently yeah we interviewed phil
lord chris miller before the show
premiered in February and in talking to
them they they told us that the germ for
the show really came from this idea
obviously it's a time-worn sci fi true
you know apocalypse wipes out humanity
one one person is left it gives me the
feeling of the stands sometimes oh yeah
I can see that their model was like
instead of Charlton Heston at the end of
Planet of the Apes what if it was
someone who was completely ill-equipped
to handle getting back into society and
in whatever rudimentary form and that
made he's such a he's such a jerk he's
such as a selfish guide will forte's
character whose name is Phil Miller phil
lord chris miller very funny but it's
just like it got so tough for me to
watch at times yes but i think that that
kind of ill-equipped character is like a
recipe for comedy like it reminds me of
neil the butte plays and it just kind of
looks like watching a nature show you
can just see these other people acting
in these horrible ways that kind of
recall your real life but not so i just
kind of thing but like the force
proximity equals comedy and that you
just kind of get to see them grow week
after week i think you've got a higher
threshold definitely for that than I do
I mean I certainly recognized it's a
funny show yes you have to admit got
better as they added more and more
characters I've still got more tolerable
yeah dude he's being forced to evolve
which is why you're kind of seeing the
growth of civilization at this vastly
accelerated pace in in the confines of a
very strange sitcom that's deep I like
that
yeah but while he is not even the last
man on earth as we know now last man on
earth is not the last show on earth so
we're gonna have plenty more TV to talk
about in weeks to come as well as lots
of other stuff yeah so we hope you'll
come back and join us on split screen